بضربات مركزه تواصل روسيا استهداف العصب
الاوكراني الحساس على امتداد خريطتها في
وقت يبدو الاصعب اي البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
في فصل الشتاء
السلطات الاوكرانيه قالت ان مسيرات
انتحاريه ضربت البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في
اوديستا وان الاف الاشخاص ذات بلا كهرباء
ولا مياه ومثل هذا الحال من انقطاع
لامدادات المياه والكهرباء المناطق في
مكلايف وخيرسون احدثه قصف روسي وفقا
لمسؤولين اوكرانيين
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه وصفه الهجمه الروسيه
المستمره منذ اكتوبر الماضي على النظام
الطاقه بغير المسبوقه في العالم وقالت ان
الضربات الروسيه المتعمده تستهدف بدقه
مولدات الكهرباء وشبكه نقلهم انطلاقا من
معرفه الروسي بمنظومه الطاقه الاوكرانيه
كما تحدث مسؤولون اوكرانيون قبل ايام عن
ان اكثر من 500
كهرباء بفعل ضربات القوات الروسيه وبنفس
الاتهام تواجه القوات الاوكرانيه
مواليه لروسيا في اقليم دومباز قالت ان
الاوكرانيين يتعمدون استهداف البنيه
التحتيه واخرها قصف بصوارخ هاي مارس
الامريكيه استهدف منشات للبنيه التحتيه في
مقاطعه لوجانز لا يخفي المسؤولون الروس
لاستهداف المتعمد من قواتهم لمنشات الطاقه
في اوكرانيا وهو من وجهه نظرهم رد مناسب
معتبرين ان الاوكرانيين هم من بداوا ضرب
المنشات الروسيه المدنيه وابرزها تفجير
جسر القرم في اكتوبر الماضي ومن نتج عنه
من ضرر جزئي رغم ان كياب لم تعلن صراحه
مسؤوليتها عن تفجير الجسر الحيوي